[Music]
important
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello there i'm nazarez and welcome to
rt essentials we are living in
extraordinary times especially when it
comes to entertainment we've got
streamers galore packed with endless
selections all at our fingertips and yes
you can still stop by and see your old
friend mr movie theater if you're
feeling adventurous but there's no
denying the perks of this modern era and
one of the biggest perks is having more
access to international and foreign
language films i mean what better way to
immerse yourself in another culture than
to kick back switch on those subtitles
and take in the cinematic tales of
people in places that are unfamiliar
i mean sure you could travel to faraway
lands but who other than every person
you follow on instagram has the time or
money to do that i mean seriously do
those people work why is everyone in
europe
anyways today we are going to be honing
in on the most groundbreaking spanish
language films ever
movies not only starring and produced by
spanish filmmakers but movies that are
entirely in spanish and with
spanish-made films gaining more
notoriety globally the what to watch
decision fatigue is real so let us come
in and help you out these are our
selections for the best spanish language
movies
el mariachi
guess what
your little friends are right here
but not for long
they have something they want to scream
to you
so listen very carefully
because i want you to repeat this to me
when i come visit you
[Applause]
el mariachi released in 1993 was
legendary filmmaker robert rodriguez's
directorial debut it featured a
predominantly amateur cast and was
filmed in various locations around the
city of acuna located in the mexican
state of kuahila now it's the story of a
traveling guitar player with a modest
desire to play music for a living but
when he stops at a bar in a tiny town
his simple life is interrupted by local
hitmen who mistake him for an enemy
assassin
now you're probably more familiar with
the sequel films and rodriguez's mexico
trilogy desperado and once upon a time
in mexico and that's because they
featured an a-list cast and had a hefty
budget to work with but el mariachi the
one that started it all was made on a
shoestring budget of just over seven
thousand dollars and thonces
you must be the mariachi who came into
my town
killed my men
and ran off with my virgin
and you're talented also
i hear you real good at playing your
guitar
even for the early 90s and even for an
at the time no name director i mean
that's pennies fractions of pennies in
the film world and yet despite the
limited funds el mariachi was an
actioner packed with shootouts gritty
characters and plenty of nods to the
spaghetti western era of movies
the camera work was crafty the plot
gripping the stakes high and the tone is
serious and engaging yet hilarious for
real i mean this film is super funny and
it's no easy feat to balance humor and
drama like that and to package it in a
way that connects with audiences
directors will spend decades trying to
master such dynamics and yet rodriguez
nailed it on his first try i mean the
guy's got natural style mucho estila
[Music]
my
wreck
wreck is a found footage horror film
co-directed by huame balaguero and paco
plaza and it was released in november
2007. it stars spanish actress manuela
velasco who actually made her film debut
in pedro almodovar's law of desire
definitely check that one out if you
haven't it has a 100 tomato meter score
i mean need i say more back to wreck
though velasco plays angela vidal a
reporter who along with her cameraman
records the horrifying outbreak of a
disease that turns humans into vicious
cannibals and because that isn't scary
and stressful enough police and military
have sealed off the apartment building
where the outbreak is spreading and
trapped vidal inside now this plot
sounds familiar it's because rec was
remade for american audiences and
released is quarantined in 2008. wreck
was filmed in spain with the zombie
infused apartment building located on
ramla de catalunya a bustling street in
central barcelona
[Music]
similar to rodriguez balaguero was
working with a modest budget only two
million dollars okay so it's a lot more
than seven thousand but still for a
feature length film two million is not a
lot and with that modest budget
balaguero managed to make one of the
most terrifying horror films of all time
certainly in the found footage sub-genre
the bbc called it quote a runaway roller
coaster of a freight flick and empire
magazine wrote that it's a handheld
zombie flick with more than enough
shocks to hold its own wreck also
spawned a successful film series which
includes three sequels the latest of
which wreck iv apocalypse was released
in 2014. velasco's performance won her a
goya award for best new actress and for
those unfamiliar with the goya awards
they're essentially the oscars of spain
so this is a huge accomplishment but
still it doesn't make up for the fact
that you trapped her in an apartment
building filled with flesh-eating
zombies
roma
estonia
is
[Music]
[Music]
roma is set in mexico city in the 1970s
and follows live in housekeeper gleo one
of the two domestic workers who help
antonio and sophia an upper middle class
couple take care of their four children
now complications soon arise when
antonio runs away with his mistress and
cleo finds out that she's pregnant not
cool antonio sophia decides to take a
vacation with the kids and invites cleo
along for a much needed getaway to clear
her mind and bond with the family and
the film gets its name for being set in
the colonia roma neighborhood which is
where writer director alfonso cuaron
grew up in fact juaron has admitted that
roma was as autobiographical as it can
be adding that 90 comes out of his
memory and they actually shot in the
places where the scenes took place
plus he gathered most of the original
furniture in his home from different
family members all around mexico and
cast actors that looked as much as
possible like the original people
oh
poured his heart and soul into this
deeply personal feature and it paid off
because roma was one of the most
critically acclaimed films of the decade
the new yorker wrote that quote it is
the clarity of guadal's eye and the sea
like sway of his remembrance that compel
you to trust the tale that he tells
and touching on the film seems the
washington post wrote that roma achieves
a rare feat of making the personal
authentically political not through
explicit polemic or tortured metaphors
but simply by observing life with enough
perspective to reflect in it all its
contradictions additionally roma was
nominated for 10 oscars at the 91st
academy awards winning for best director
best cinematography and best foreign
language film this is the first mexican
entry to ever win best foreign language
film it's the first foreign language
film to ever win best director and it is
the first film distributed primarily by
a streaming service netflix to be
nominated for best picture i mean yeah
yeah we get it roma is incredible but we
haven't even begun to grasp the gravity
of quarton's work
is
the 2006 drama evolved which features an
ensemble cast that includes penelope
cruz carmen mora and lola duenas cruz
plays raymunda a mother working and
living in madrid with her despicable
husband paco and her daughter paula her
sister lives nearby and they both miss
her mother irene who tragically died in
a house fire several years prior but
there's more to this story than you
might think like a murder in
self-defense which results in a body
being stowed away in a restaurant
freezer a ghost who hides out in the
trunk of a car and poses as a russian
immigrant and well incest i mean don't
look at me i didn't write the movie
almost wrote it and interestingly enough
took the plot from a novel featured in
one of his earlier films the flower of
my secrets
about
in which said novel is rejected by the
main character's publisher for being too
dark but then gets stolen and turned
into a film i know it's confusing but
let me clarify
volved is a film based on a novel in
another film that gets turned into a
film
i think i made it worse
it doesn't matter what matters is that
volver has been hailed by critics as a
quote visually stunning clever and
entertaining film
timeout wrote that almodovar is smart
enough not to rest on laughs alone and
that he quote extends his premise to
dark though occasionally tidy
psychological territory
roger ebert.com gave it four stars and
called it enchanting gentle and
transgressive the role of raimondo also
earned cruz an oscar nomination for best
actress the first spanish woman to ever
be nominated in that category
hands labyrinth
you must have known that mexican-born
guillermo del toro would make it on this
list because he is after all one of the
greatest living filmmakers
and one of his pinnacle works is the
dark fantasy drama pans labyrinth
set in 1944 spain it's the story of a
young girl named ophelia who arrives at
the army post of her ailing mother's new
husband captain vidal navidal is a
phalange officer deranged psychopathic
and desperately trying to thwart off a
spanish maquis uprising now while
exploring an ancient labyrinth ophelia
encounters a mysterious fawn pan who
tells her that she is a legendary lost
princess and must complete three
dangerous tasks in order to claim
immortality now del toro considers this
story a parable and the film perfectly
intertwines dispiriting historical
events with fairy tale elements the
mundane with the magic
is
[Music]
foreign
the film explores complex scenes like
morality free will and escapism and many
see it as a metaphor for war-related
trauma now on the technical front you'd
be hard-pressed to find a more visually
impressive film and that's largely
because pan's labyrinth blends with
animatronics with cgi and utilized
cinematographer guillermo navarro who is
a frequent collaborator of del toro and
robert rodriguez and speaking of other
mexican filmmakers alfonzo cuaron was a
producer on this film which only helped
to increase its chances for success and
bet your devil's backbone that this one
succeeded pan's labyrinth grossed 84
million dollars and it won numerous
awards including oscars for best
cinematography best production design
and best makeup and hair styling and
agoya for best new actress ivana baquero
who played ophelia
the orphanage
marina
barcelona-born director juan antonio
bayona made his feature-length debut
with the 2007 gothic horror the
orphanage the plot centers on laura
played by belen
who fondly looks back on her childhood
in an orphanage so much so that she
convinces her husband to buy the place
and help her convert it into a home for
sick children now since i already
mentioned that this is a horror flick
you can surmise that things are gonna go
south pretty quickly and they do one day
laura's own adopted son simon disappears
simon is critically ill and after being
missing for several months is presumed
dead now grief stricken laura believes
she's hearing spirits who may or may not
be helping her to relocate poor little
simon bayona had seen belen's
performance in the sea inside and knew
that she was the one to play laura
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
during interviews belen stated that
biona insisted that she watched the film
close encounters of the third kind
something that she didn't understand at
the time but after watching everything
clicked and she saw the way richard
dreyfuss's character roy changes
throughout the film he believes that
what he's seen is the truth despite
everyone else thinking that he's crazy
and belen's character laura is faced
with the same dilemma psychological and
emotional stress now the orphanage was a
commercial success earning almost 80
million dollars on a budget of just 4
million though biona now knows all about
commercial success considering his film
jurassic world fallen kingdom is one of
the top 20 grossing movies in history
but the orphanage wasn't all about the
nero it also won seven goya awards and
was critically praised for its direction
acting and visual style
and your mother
[Music]
next up is the 2001 film
or in english and your mom too relax
it's not an install it's just a title
but you can take it up with alfonso
quite on and his brother carlos because
they're the ones who wrote it set in
late 90s mexico the film follows julio
and tenoch two 17 year old boys whose
lives are ruled by raging hormones
intense friendships and a headlong rush
into adulthood now over the course of a
summer the two best friends take a
carefree cross-country road trip with a
gorgeous woman in her late 20s and also
find connection with each other
themselves and the world around them now
this was technically kwadon's fourth
film but it represented his return to
mexico having just made the american
films a little princess and great
expectations
for itoma tambien cuaron hoped to
reconnect with his passion for cinema
stating that he wanted to make the film
he was going to make before he went to
film school a film in spanish and a road
movie involving a journey to the beach
so quad on called his brother and said
let's write a movie
in el centro de salud santa maria
colotepec
a petition
and when it came to film he got away
from the production techniques
associated with hollywood and instead
embraced a documentary realist style
similar to roma quadon was inspired by
his own life specifically the trips that
he took during his youth though he did
admit neither him or his brother got to
take those trips with a beautiful
spanish woman itoma tambien set the
record for the highest box office
opening in mexico cinema history which
was made even more impressive by the
fact that the mexican directorate of
radio television and cinema slapped the
film with the highest possible rating 18
plus alfonso and his brother were so
outraged by this decision that they
actually ended up suing the rtc but
lawsuits aside nobody could have stopped
this film from gaining the recognition
it deserved and ito matambian earned an
oscar nomination for best original
screenplay and a golden globe nomination
for best foreign language film
scene hombre
[Music]
is a 2009 mexican american thriller
written and directed by kyrie joji
fukunaga it follows saida a honduran
teen who longs for a better life that
opportunity presents itself when she's
reunited with her strange father who
intends to immigrate to mexico and then
enter the united states cyrus life then
collides with a pair of mexican gang
members who have boarded the same
american bound train sin nombre was
fukunaga's feature-length debut but it's
similar to a short film that he had
directed while attending nyu entitled
victoria parachino that short film was
based on a real incident that took place
in victoria texas where a truckload of
passengers who were immigrating to the
united states died of heat exhaustion
after being abandoned by their driver
fukunaga had written an article about
this tragedy which inspired him to make
the short film and that film's success
put him on the map and gave him the
boost that he needed to then make sin
nombre which translates to without a
name
right out of the gate fukunaga proved to
be a visionary with a passion for human
rights and scene nombre was met with
rave reviews the washington post called
it quote pure filmmaking and a great
story told in beautiful images and the
associated press wrote that si nombre is
at once subtle and intense familiar but
refreshing intimate even as it tells the
story untold numbers have endured
most importantly fukunaga has given a
name a face and a story to a demographic
that deserves to be represented
pain and glory
yo
last but certainly not least is pain and
glory a 2019 drama written and directed
by pedro almodovar it's a story of an
aging spanish film director named
salvador malo played by antonio banderas
who is in the middle of a creative
crisis and revisits memorable events of
his past in addition to banderas the
film starred asiere exciandia and
penelope cruz now ahmadabad has gained
recognition with the success of his
films women on the verge of a nervous
breakdown tie me up tie me down high
heels and live flesh but it was his next
two films all about my mother and talked
to her that earned him an oscar each one
for best international feature film and
one for best original screenplay
[Music]
now these wins catapulted his career and
by the time pain and glory was released
alma davad was an international
sensation with a cult following and far
too many accolades to count i mean
seriously we could fill up an entire
episode just listing his awards
the point is many directors that reached
the level of success almadovar has have
also reached their creative key and
their subsequent work seems to
deteriorate in quality kind of like
banderas character salvador except alma
levar seems to only get better in time
like a fine rioja grand prix
and painting glory was considered one of
his finest works to date
it received two oscar nods one for best
international feature film and one for
best actor banderas and was critically
praised with time magazine and the new
york times naming it the best film of
the year
and there you have it my friends our
picks for the best spanish language
movies i know there are many others but
we can only cover so much but if we miss
the title that you think deserves to be
on this list don't go all at mariachi
and start pulling weapons out of your
guitar case we have got plenty of
episodes of rt essentials coming your
way and we will get there soon enough
thanks again for tuning in i'm nas perez
and i'll leave you with one of my
favorite quotes from guillermo del toro
there is beauty and humility and
imperfection
[Music]
you